last time we started talking about Ross
theorem and we showed a Fourier analytic
proof of Ross theorem in the finite
field model so roster in F 3 to the N
and I want you today show you how to
modify that proof to work in integers
and this will be basically Ross original
proof office theorem so what we'll prove
today is the statement that the size of
the largest three ap3 subset of 1 to n
is at most and divided by log log n ok
so we'll proof a bound of this form the
strategy of this proof will be very
similar to the one that we have from
last time so let me review for you what
is the strategy
so from last time the proof had three
main steps in the first step we observed
that if you are in a three AP three set
then there exists a large Fourier
coefficient from this Fourier
coefficient we were able to extract a
large subspace where there's a density
increment I want to modify that strategy
so that we can work in the integers
unlike in f2 to the M where things were
fairly nice and clean and because you
have subspaces you can you know take a
Fourier coefficient pass down to a
subspace there's no subspaces there are
no subspaces in integers so we'll have
to do something slightly different but
in the same spirit so you'll find a
large Fourier coefficient
and we will find that there's density
increment when you restrict not to
subspaces but what could play the role
of subspaces when it comes to the
integers so I want something which looks
like a smaller version of the original
space so instead of open integers if we
restrict to a sub progression so to a
smaller arithmetic progression and we'll
show that you can restrict to a sub
progression where you can obtain density
increment or restrict integers to
something smaller and then same as last
time we can iterate this inner increment
to obtain the conclusion that you have
an upper bound on the size of this 383
set okay so that's the strategy so you
see the same strategy as the one we did
last time and many of the ingredients
will have parallels but the execution
will be slightly different especially in
the second step where because we no
longer have subspaces which are nice and
clean so that's why we started with a
finite fuel model just to show how
things work in a slightly easier setting
and today we'll see how to do the same
kind of strategy here where there's
going to be a bit more work but not too
much more bit more work so before we
start any questions
all right so last time I used the proof
of rostrum as an excuse to introduce
Fourier analysis and we're gonna see
basically the same kind of Fourier
analysis but it's going to take on a
slightly different form because we're
not working at three to the N I work
working inside the integers and there's
a general theory of Fourier analysis on
the group abelian groups I don't want to
go into that theory because it's I want
to focus on the specific case but the
points are given in a median group you
always have a dual group do group of
characters and they play the role of
Fourier transform specifically in the
case of Z we have the following Fourier
transform so the dual group of Z turns
out to be a torus so real numbers mod
one and the Fourier transform it's the
finest follows starting with a function
the integers if you like let's say it's
finally supported just to make our lives
a bit easier don't have to deal with
technicalities but in general the
following formula holds we have this
Fourier transform defined by setting F
hat of theta to be the following some
where this e is somewhat standard
notation additive combinatorics it's e
to the 2 pi I so it goes a fraction T
around the complex unit circle okay so
that's the Fourier transform on the
integers you might have seen this before
under a different name this is usually
called for you serious you know the
notation may be slightly different okay
so that's that's always see today and
this Fourier transform plays the same
role as the Fourier transform from last
time which was on the group F 3 to the M
and just as in the last time we had a
number of important identities and will
have the same kinds of identities so let
me remind you what they are and the
proofs are all basically the same so I
won't show you the proofs I've had 0 is
simply the sum of over the domain we
have this plancherel possible identity
which tells us that if you look at the
inner product by linear form in the
physical space it equals to the inner
product in the Fourier space
in the physical space now use some in
the frequency space you take integral
over the torus or the circle in this
case it's a one dimensional tourism
there's also the Fourier inversion
formula which now says that f of X is
equal to F hat of theta G of X theta
you can't equate theta from zero to one
on the torus circle and third and
finally there was this identity last
time that related sweet home arithmetic
progressions to the Fourier transform
okay so this last one was slightly not
asked I mean it's not as standard as the
first several which are standard for
your identities but this one will be
useful to us so the identity relating
the Fourier transform the three a piece
now has the following form okay so if we
define lambda of F and G and H to be the
following sum which sums over all three
a piece in the integers then one can
write this expression in terms of the
Fourier transform as follows
so compared to this formula to the one
that we saw from last time it's the same
formula there are different domains
where you're summing or integrating or
it's the same formula and the proof is
the same go look at the proof it's the
same proof okay so these are the key
Fourier things that we'll use and then
we'll try to follow our nose with the
same as a proof as last time and see
where we can get so let me introduce one
more notation so I'll write lambda sub 3
of F to be lambda of F F F three times
okay well at this point if you
understood the lecture from last time
none of anything I've said so far should
be surprising we are working integers so
we should look at the corresponding
Fourier transform in integers and if we
follow your nose this is all the things
that we're going to use okay so what was
one of the first things we mentioned
regarding the Fourier transform from
last time after this point
okay so let's do a counting lemma so
what should a counting lemma say what
the spirit of the counting lemma is that
if you have two functions that are close
to each other and how close means
closing for you then their corresponding
number of three peas should be similar
so so that's what we want to say indeed
so the County lemma for us will say that
if F and G are functions on Z and such
that they're l2 norms are both bounded
by this M sum of the squared absolute
value entries are both bounded then the
difference of their three applicants
should not be so different from each
other if F and G are closing for you and
that means if all the Fourier
coefficients of F minus G are small then
lambda 3 FF which considers three AP
counting F is close to that of G okay
same kind of three AP counting lama from
last time so let's prove it as with
accounting lemma proofs you've seen
several times already in this course we
will prove it by first writing this
difference as a telescoping sum the
first term being F minus G F and then G
of F minus G F the lambda G G minus G
and we would like to show that each of
these terms is small if F minus G has
small fourier coefficients so let's
found the first term so let me bound
this first term using the 3 AP identity
relating through AP to Fourier
coefficients we can write this lambda as
the following integral over Fourier
coefficients
and now let me okay so what was the
trick last time so we said let's pull
out one of these guys and then use
triangle inequality on the remaining
factors so we'll do that so far so good
and now you see this integral by Cauchy
Schwarz Cauchy Schwarz the fast first
factor you got this L to sum this L to
integral and then you apply Cauchy
Schwarz to the second factor now what do
we do
okay so yeah so you see in l2 or Fourier
the first automatic reaction should be
to use plan Tyrell or Percival so apply
apply plan to RL identity to each of
these factors we find that each of those
factors is equal to this L to some in
the physical space this square root the
same thing screwed again okay and then
we find that because there was a
hypothesis in the hypothesis towards a
pound and on this the sum of squares and
similarly with the other two terms okay
so that proves the county memo
okay great
so the question its last time we had a
counting lemma that looked slightly
different but I claimed they're all
really the same counting lemma they're
all the same proofs if you run this
proof it won't work if you take what we
did last time it's the same kind of
proofs so last time we had a counting
number where we had the same FF
essentially well now I have allow you to
essentially take three different things
and okay so both in both cases you're
running through this calculation but
they look slightly different I agree it
doesn't look exactly the same but if you
think about what's involved in the proof
they're the same proofs any more
questions all right so now we have this
County lemma so let's start our proof of
Roth's theorem in the integers as with
last time there will be three steps as
mentioned up there okay in the first
step
let us show that if you are three AP
free then we can obtain a density a
large Fourier coefficient
so in this course it's this counting
number we actually saw just basically
this kind of proof for the first time
when we discussed graph counting lemma
back in the chapter on samurai deist
regularity lemma and sure they all look
literally not exactly the same but
they're all really the same kind of
proofs I'm showing you the same thing in
many different guises but they're all
the same proofs so if you are a set free
I'm ice with last time I'm going to call
alpha the density of a now inside this
progression this length end progression
and suppose n is large enough so the
conclusion now is that there exists some
theta such that if you look at this sum
over here as I sum over both integers
actually I mean do the sum only from one
to uppercase n I claim that it's saying
what this title says if you are 383 and
this end is large enough relative to the
density you think of this density alpha
is a constant then I can find a large
Fourier coefficient you know there's a
small difference and this is related to
what you were asking earlier between how
we set things up now versus will happen
last time so last time we just look
for a Fourier coefficient corresponding
in tune non zero are now I'm not
restricting non zero but I don't start
with an indicator function I start with
the demeaned indicator function I take
out a me so that the zeroth coefficient
so to speak which corresponds to the
mean is already zero so you don't get to
use that for your coefficient so if you
didn't do this if you just try to do
this last time and you can also do the
exactly the same setup but if you don't
be mean it then if you don't have this
term then this statement is trivially
true because I can take theta equal to
zero that's but I don't want I want to I
want an actual significant Fourier
improvement so I take I do this demean
and then I consider its Fourier
coefficient okay any questions about the
statement yeah so this demeaning is
really important alright so that's
something that's a very common technique
whenever you do these kinds of analyses
let's make sure you're okay so that
you're so you're looking at functions
with mean zero we have the following
information about 3p counts in a because
a is 3 P 3 so what is the value of
lambda sub 3 of the indicator of a
lambda of three if you look at the
expression it basically sums over all 3
a piece but a has no 3 a piece except
for the trivial ones so you only
consider the trivial 3 a piece which has
size exactly the size of a which is
alpha N from trivial
3a please on the other hand what do we
know about lambda 3 of this interval
from 1 to n ok so how many 3 a piece are
there roughly it's going to be about N
squared over 2 at least n squared over 2
because to generate a 3 AP I just have
to pick a first term and the third term
and I'm okay as long as they're the same
parity then you have a 3 so same parity
cuts you down by half so you have at
least n squared over 2 3 a piece so now
let's look at how to apply the counting
lemma to this setting so we have the
counting lemma up there where I now want
to apply it so apply counting to on one
hand the indicator function of a so so
we get a count 3 piecing a but also
compared to the normalized indicator on
the interval okay so maybe this is a
good point for me to pause and remind
you that the spirit of this whole proof
is understanding structure versus pseudo
randomness as was was with the case last
time so we want to understand in what
ways is a pseudo random and here pseudo
random just as what last time means
having small Fourier coefficients being
for a uniform if a pseudo random which
here means F and G are close to each
other that's what being school rehna
means then the county line I will tell
us the F and G should have
a peek house but a has basically no AP
account so they should not be close to
each other so so that's right so that's
the strategy to show that a is not
pseudo-random in this sense and thereby
extracting a large Fourier coefficient
so we apply counting to these two
functions and we obtain that so this
quantity which corresponds to lambda 3
of G minus alpha n difference is upper
bounded by the using the counting lemma
we find that their difference is upper
bounded by the following quantity
namely you look at the difference
between F and G and evaluate us maximum
Fourier coefficient so if a is
pseudo-random meaning that for a uniform
this L infinity norm is small then I
should expect lots and lots of 3a
piecing it but because that is not the
case we should be able to conclude that
there is some large Fourier coefficient
so thus rearranging the equation above
we have that ok so we have this
expression here and now we are ok so let
me simplify this expression slightly and
now we're using that and it's
sufficiently large so where n is
sufficiently large so this quantity is
at least a tenth of alpha squared n and
that's the conclusion all right so
that's the conclusion of this step here
what is this mean this means there
exists some theta so that the Fourier
coefficient at theta is at least the
claimed quantity
any questions so that finishes step one
so now let me go on to step two in step
two we wish to show that if you have a
large for your coefficient then one can
obtain a density increment so last time
we were working in a finite field vector
space a fourier coefficient which is a
dual vector corresponds to some
hyperplane and having a large fourier
coefficient then implies that the
density of a on the co set of those
hyper planes must be not all close to
each other so one of the hyper planes
must have significantly higher density
than the rest okay so we want to do
something similar here except we run
into this technical difficulty where
there are no subspaces anymore right so
the Fourier character namely
corresponding to this theta is just a
real number it doesn't divide up your
space doesn't divide up you one two and
very nice thing to sub chunks but we
still want to use this data to chop up
one to n into smaller spaces so that we
can iterate and do density increment all
right so let's see what we can do
so given this data
what we would like to do is to partition
this one through n into sub progressions
okay so chop up one to n into sub a
piece such that if you evaluate so this
data is fixed so on each sub ap this
function here is roughly constant on
each of your parts last time we had this
for a character and then we chopped it
up using these three hyperplanes
and on each hyperplane the 48 character
is literally constant that's what we
worked with and now you cannot get them
to be exactly constant but the next best
thing we can hope for is to get this
fourier character to be roughly constant
okay so we're going to do some
partitioning that allows us to achieve
this characteristic and let me give you
some intuition about why this is true
and this is not exactly a surprise in
fact the intuition is just that if you
look at what this function behaves like
so what's going on here you are on the
unit circle and you are jumping by theta
so you just keep jumping by theta and so
on and I want to show that I can chop up
my progression into a bunch of almost
periodic pieces where in each part
I'm staying inside a small arc and so in
the extreme case of this where it is
very easy to see is if X is some
rational number
a overbeat with be fairly small then we
can so then this character is actually
constant a piece with common different
speed
I so theta theta thank you theta 2 pi
if theta is some rational with some
small denominator so then you are
literally jumping in periodic steps on
the unit circle so if you partition and
according to the exact same periods you
have you have that this character is
exactly constant on each of your
progressions now in general the theta
you get out of that proof might not have
this very nice form but we can at least
approximately achieve the desired effect
any questions
[Applause]
okay so to achieve approximately girth
desired effect what we'll do is to find
something so that B times theta is not
quite an integer but very close to an
integer okay so this probably many of
you seen before it's a classic
pigeonhole type result so if you have
think of a real number and a delta kind
of a tolerance then there exists a
positive integer T at most one over
delta such that the times theta is very
close to an integer so this norm here is
distance to the closest integer
alright alright so the proof here is by
pigeonhole principle so if we let M be 1
over Delta round down and consider the
numbers 0 theta 2 theta 3 data and so on
- M theta so by pigeonhole there exists
I theta J theta some two different terms
of the sequence such that they differ by
less than most Delta in their fractional
parts so now I'll take T to be
difference between I and J ok so even
though you don't have exactly rational
we have approximately ratio so this is a
it's a simple rational approximation
statement and using this operational
approximation we can now kind of try to
do the intuition here pretending that
we're working with rational numbers so
if we take a tie between 0 & 1
theta irrational and suppose and it's
large enough okay so here C means there
exist some sufficiently large some
constant C such that the statement is
true so suppose think million yeah that
should be fine so then there exists so
then one can partition one to n into sub
ApS which will call P I and each having
length between cube root of n and twice
the cube root of n such that this
character that we want to stay roughly
constant indeed does not change very
much if you look at two terms in the
same AP in the same sub AP then the
value of this character each P sub I is
roughly the same so they don't vary by
more than Etta on each P I right so here
we're partitioning this one to n into a
sub a piece so that this guy here stays
roughly constant
okay any questions alright so think
about how you might prove this let's
take a quick break so you see we are
basically following the same strategy as
a proof from last time but this second
step which we're all right now needs to
be somewhat modified because you cannot
cut this space up into pieces where your
character is constant if they're roughly
constant then we're good to go so that's
what we're doing now so let's prove the
statement up there so let's prove this
statement over here
so using we find that there exists some
D okay so write down some number for now
don't worry about any more come up short
you why I write this specific quantity
so there exist some D just not too big
such that
d theta is very close to an integer so
now I'm merely applying for excellent
okay so given such D and so how big is
this T you see that because I assumed
that n is sufficiently large if we
choose that seed large enough T is at
most root n so given such T which is at
most root n you can partition 1 to n
into sub progressions with common
difference D essentially look at residue
classes mod T so they're all going to
have length by basically and over D and
I chopped them up a little bit further
to get so a piece of lengths between
cube root of N and twice cube root of N
so I'm going to make sure that all of my
ApS are roughly the same length and now
inside each sub progression let me call
the sub progression P prime sub
progression P let's look at how much
this character value can vary inside
this progression so we how much can this
can this very well because theta is such
that D times theta is very close to an
integer and the length of each
progression is not too large here I want
some control on the length so we find
that the maximum variation is at most
the size of P the length of P times so
this that difference over there all of
these are exponential so I can shift
them well the length of P is at most
twice cube root of n and okay so what is
this quantity so the point is that if
this fractional part here is very close
to an integer then e to that number you
to the 2pi times that item number should
be very close to one because what's
happening here this is the distance
between those two points on a circle
which is and most bounded by the length
of the arc
okay so court length and most out of the
arc so now you put everything here
together and applying the bound that we
got D theta so this is the reason for
choosing that we are number up there we
find that variation within each
progression is at most eight so
variation of this character within each
progression it's not very large and that
that's the claim any questions so this
is the analogous claim to the one that
we have the one that we used last time
where we said that the character is
constant on each cosine of the
hyperplane not exactly constant but
almost good enough
all right so the goal of step two is to
show an energy so a density increment
that if you have a large Fourier
coefficient then we want to claim that
the density goes up significantly on
some sub progression and the next part
the next lemma will get us to that goal
and this part is very similar to the one
that we saw from last time but with this
new partition in - density alpha and
exist some progression sub progression I
just mean that I'm starting with
original progression 1 to N and I'm
zooming in to some sub progression with
the length of P fairly long so the
length appears at least cube root of N
and such that a when restricted to this
sub progression has a density increment
so originally the density of a is alpha
so we're zooming into some sub
progression P with a pretty long sub
progression where the density goes up
significantly from a to essentially a
from alpha to roughly alpha plus alpha
squared okay
all right so we start with a 383 set so
from step one there exists some data
with large code so a corresponds to a
large Fourier coefficient so this sum
here
and now we use okay so step one this
consequence and from this data now we
apply the lemma up there too so we apply
lemma where let's say ha being alpha
squared over 30 the exact constants are
not so important when we apply the lemma
to partition and into a bunch of sub
progressions which we'll call p1 through
p8 and each of these progressions have
length between cube root of n and twice
and I want to understand what happens to
the density of a when restricted to
these progressions so starting with this
inequality over here which suggests to
us that there must be some deviation so
starting starting with what we saw and
now inside each progression this the X
theta is roughly constant so if you
pretend them as actually constant I can
break up this Sun depending on where the
XS lie so I from 1 okay and let me sum
inside each progression okay so by
triangle inequality
I can upper bound the first sum by where
I now cut some into progression by
progression and on each progression this
character is roughly constant so let me
take out the maximum possible deviations
from them being constant so upper bound
again you find that we can essentially
pretend so if each exponential is
constant on each sub progression then I
- well just have this sum here but I
lose a little bit because it's not
exactly constants almost constant so I
lose a little bit and that little bit is
this
lose that little bit of a tub and so on
each progression P I you lose almost
something that's essentially of a square
times the length of P i okay now you see
I've chosen the error parameter so that
everything I've lost is no not so much
more than the initial bound I began with
so in particular we see that even if we
have pretended that the characters were
constant on each progression we would
have still obtained some lower bound on
the total deviation okay and what is
this quantity over here or you see I'm
restricting each some to each sub
progression but this sum here even
though it's the sum but it's really
counting how many elements of a are in
that progression so this sum over here
is the same thing okay so let me write
it Newport
so so what we have so the left-hand side
over there is this quantity here we see
that the right-hand side even though you
have that sum it is really just counting
how many elements of a are in each
progression versus how many you should
expect based on the overall density of a
so that should look similar to what we
got last time I know the intuition
should be that well if the average
deviation is large then one of them one
of these terms should have the density
increment if you try to do the next step
somewhat naively you run into an issue
because it could be here you have K
terms it could be that you have all the
densities except for one going up only
slightly and one density dropping
dramatically in which case you might not
have a significant density increment
right so we want to show that on some
progression the density increases
significantly so far from this
inequality we just know that there is
some sub progression where the density
changes significantly but of course the
overall density the average density
should remain constant so if some goes
up others must go down but if you just
try to do an averaging argument you have
to be careful so so there was a trick
last time which we didn't really mean
last time but now now it's much more you
more useful where I want to show that if
this holds then some P I sees a large
and it sees a large density increment
and to do that let me rewrite this
as the following so I keep the same
expression and I add a term which is the
same thing but without the absolute
value okay so you see these guys stay
total to zero so adding that term it
doesn't change my expression but now the
summon is always non-negative so it's
either zero or twice this number
depending on the sign of okay so
comparing left hand side right hand side
we see that there must be some I so
hence this sum I such that the left hand
side the ice term on the left hand side
is less than or equal to the ice term on
the right hand side and in particular
that term should be positive so it
implies okay so how can how can you get
this inequality with it in pies simply
that the restriction of a to this pie is
at least alpha plus alpha squared over
40 times so this claim here just says
that on the ice progression there's a
significant energy increment if it's
worth decrement that term could have
been zero
okay so this achieves what we were
looking for in step two namely to find
that there's a density increment on some
long sub progression now we can go to
step three which is basically the same
as we saw last time
where now we want to iterate this
density increment okay so it's basically
the same argument as last time you start
with density alpha and each step in the
integration the density goes up quite a
bit and we want to control the total
number of steps knowing that the final
density at most one always okay so how
many steps can you take so this was the
same argument that we saw last time you
see that starting with alpha or not
alpha if doubles after certain number of
steps we double after okay so how many
steps do you need well I want to get
from alpha 2 to alpha so I need at most
alpha over 40 steps ok so last time I
was slightly sloppy and so there's a
basically a floor up or floor down
sitting up or down situation but I
should add a plus one yeah
40 40 over alpha so you double after at
most that many steps and then now you
are at density at least 2 alpha so we
double after at most 20 over alpha steps
and so on and we double at most
basically log sub 2 of 1 over alpha
times okay so anyway putting everything
together we see that the total number of
steps
yes and most on the order of 1 over
alpha when you stop you can only stop
for one reason because in the so so in
step 1
remember the iteration said that the
process terminates process can always go
on and it terminates if the length 2 now
a step I so let ni be the length of the
progression that step I is at most C
times alpha I to the minus 12 provided
that n is large enough you can always
pass to a sub progression and here you
know when you pass the sub progression
of course you can read label that sub
progression and it's now 1 through n I
so I can it's all the progressions are
basically the same as the first set of
positive integers prefix of the positive
integers so when we stop a step I you
must have n sub I being
most this quantity over here which is at
most C times the initial density raised
to this minus 12 so therefore the
initial length n of the space is bounded
by each time we went down by a cube root
at most right so you find if you stop a
step I then the initial length is at
most n sub I to the 3 times 3 to the
power of I each time you're doing a cube
root okay so you put everything together
that most time in the iterations when
you stop the length is at most this so
you put them together and then you find
that the n must be at most double
exponential in 1 over the density in
other words density is at most 1 over
log log n which is what we claimed in
Ross theorem okay so that finishes the
proof
[Applause]
any questions so the message here is
that it's the same proof as last time
but we need to do a bit more work and
none of this work is difficult but
they're more technical and that's often
a theme that you see in additive
combinatorics this is part of the reason
why the finite field model is a really
nice playground because there are things
tend to be often cleaner but the ideas
are often similar or the same ideas not
always next lecture we'll see you one
technique where there's a dramatic
difference between the finite field
vector space and over the integers but
for many things in additive
combinatorics define a fuel vector space
is just a nicer place to be in to try
all your ideas and techniques what let
me comment on some analogies between
these two approaches and compare the
bounds so on one hand so we saw last
time is proof in FP to the end now the
integers inside this interval of length
so let me write uppercase and in both
cases to be the size of the overall
ambient space so what kind of bounds do
we get in both situations so last time
for in F 3 to the end we got a bound
which is of the order and over log n
whereas today
pound is somewhat worse a little bit
worse now we lose an extra lock so where
do we lose an extra lock in this
argument so where does these two
argument where do these two arguments
differ qualitatively okay so you're
dividing by so here in each iteration
over here your size of the iteration I
mean iteration the size of the space
goes down by a factor three whereas over
here it could go down by a cube root and
that's that's precisely right so that
explains for this extra lock in the
bounds so while this is a great analogy
it's not a perfect analogy you see there
is a divergence here between the two
situations and so then you might ask is
there some way to avoid the loss this
extra log factor loss over here is there
some way to carry out the strategy that
we did last time in a way that is much
more faithful to that strategy of
passing down to subspaces so here we
pass two progressions and because we
have do this extra you know pigeonhole
type argument it was somewhat lost we
lost a power which translated into this
extra log so it turns out there there is
some way to do this so let me just
briefly mention what's the idea that is
involved so last time we went down from
so the main objects that we were passing
or start with a vector space and passed
down to a subspace which is also a
vector space so you can define subspaces
in a street the end by the following so
I can start with some set of characters
you and I define as some set of
characters s and I define u sub s to be
basically the orthogonal complement of s
ok so this is a subspace and these were
the kind of subspaces that we saw last
time because the SS or the ARS that came
out of the proof last time every time we
saw bond we throw it in we cut down to a
smaller subspace and we repeat but the
progressions they don't really look like
this alright so the question is is there
some way to do this argument so that you
end up with progressions and look like
that and it turns out there is a way and
there are these objects which will see
more later in this course called poor
sets okay so they were used by poor gain
to mimic this machine an argument that
we saw last time more faithfully into
the integers where we're going to come
up with some set of integers that
resemble the much closed more closely
resemble this notion of subspaces
in the finite field setting and for this
it's much easier to work inside a group
so instead of working in the integers
let's work inside Z mod and Z so we can
do Fourier transform in Z mod NZ so the
discrete Fourier analysis here so in Z
mod NZ we define so given an S let's
define the spore set to be the set of
elements of NZ such that if you look at
what really is supposed to resemble this
this thing over here if this quantity is
small for all s so we put that element
into the spore set so these sets they
they function much more like subspaces
so there are the analogy of subspaces
inside G mod n Z which n is prime has no
subgroups it has no natural subspace
structure but by looking at these four
sets they provide a natural way to set
up this argument so that you can but
with much more technicalities repeat
this kind of arguments more similar to
last time but passing not subspaces but
to poor sets and and then with quite a
bit of extra work one can obtain bounds
of the quantity and over poly block so
the current best bound I mentioned last
time this of this type was just through
further refinements of this technique
questions
the last thing I want to mention today
is so far we've been talking about three
APs
so what about four term arithmetic
progressions doing any of the things
that we talked about here
work for for a piece and there's an
analogy to be made here compared to what
we discussed with graphs or so you grasp
from kind of triangle counting them on a
triangle remove all mm and then we said
that the proof for a piece we will need
the hypergraph version the simplex
removal lemma hypergraph regularity
lemma and now it's much more difficult
and that analogy carries two and the
same kind of difficulties that come up
so it can be done but you need something
more and the main message I want you to
take away is that for a piece well we
had a counting memo that says that
Fourier coefficients and Fourier
transform controls 3 MP caps it turns
out the same is not true for foil please
so for you that's not let me give you
some okay so in fact in the homework for
this week there is a specific example of
a set where it has uniformly small
Fourier coefficients but that's a wrong
number of 40-piece so the following it
is true ok so it is true that you have
some readies theorem in let's just talk
about the finite field setting where
things are bit easier to discuss so it
is true that the size of the biggest
subset of F 5 to the N is a tiny
fraction it's a little one fraction with
the entire space I use f5 here because
if I set F 3 it doesn't make sense to
talk about four ATP's so at five but it
doesn't really matter which specific
field so you can prove this using
hypergraph removal say
proof verbatim that we saw earlier if
you have hypergraph removal but if you
want to try to prove it using Fourier
analysis or it doesn't work quite using
the same strategy but in fact there is a
modification that would allow you to to
make it work but you need an extension
of Fourier analysis and it was known as
higher order for your analysis which was
an important development in modern
additive combinatorics that initially
arose in Gao versus work where he gave a
new proof of samurais theorem so towers
didn't work in this setting he worked in
integers but many of the ideas
originated from from his paper and then
subsequently developed lots of people in
various settings I just want to give you
one specific statement what this higher
order Fourier analysis looks like it's a
fancy term and you know statements often
get very technical but I just want to
give you one concrete thing to take away
all right so for for a piece higher
order for analysis roughly it also goes
by the name of quadratic for urinalysis
so let me give you a very specific
instance of the theorem and this can be
sometimes called an inverse theorem for
quadratic for you analysis
suppose okay so for every Delta there
exists some C such that following is
true if a is a subset F Phi to the N
with density alpha and such that it's so
now lambda sub four so this is the for
AP density so similar to three a people
now you write four terms the for AP
density of a differs from
alpha to the fourth by a significant
amount okay so for three a piece then we
said that now a has a large Fourier
coefficient so for okay
four for a piece that may not be true
but the following is true so then there
exists a nonzero quadratic polynomial F
in n variables over a five such that the
indicator function of a correlates with
this quadratic exponential face so free
analysis the conclusion that we got from
counting lemma is that you have some
linear function f such that this
quantity is large this large Fourier
coefficient okay so that is not true for
for a piece but what is true is that now
you can look at quadratic exponential
faces and then this true so that's the
content of higher order for you I mean
that's the example of higher order
Fourier analysis and you can imagine
with this type of result and with quite
a bit of more work you can try to follow
a similar density increment strategy to
prove similarities theorem for for a
piece